[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
[Music]
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv all the networks
all the networks person woman
man camera tv all the networks
that's amazing how did you do that
that's amazing
i do because i have like a good memory
because i'm
cognitively there
[Music]
flippy from indiana flippy from
indiana please unmute you are on the air
my friend all right can you hear me
yes i can hey david it's me um i just
was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making an only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
[Music]
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh
five and a quarter inches
i've not listened to this let's listen
to it together
and and see what it what it's about
[Music]
david jimmy from kelly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired and listen to your
[ __ ]
about unhinged trump supporters and this
and that
make yourself full of [ __ ] i i got
my hat's off for you you can't you you
you can't withstand it david you got my
information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
um that is crazy that is really really
crazy stuff
he's got to be wasted
[Music]
oh that's brilliant brilliant oh that's
brilliant
oh that's brilliant there is jimmy from
philly
oh that's brilliant in the name of jesus
from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning winning
all right okay let's uh there's just too
much going on to uh spend more time on
on that
as uh as dramatic as those beats
are uh welcome everybody we are on day
two of the biden administration
and i was ready to come up come here
today
and uh attack joe biden and
go completely crazy shot out of a cannon
saying that joe biden hasn't even come
close to doing
in his first day the things he said
would be day one priorities
and if i did that i'd be lying to you
because much to my surprise and pleasure
joe biden has now signed 27 executive
orders into place
and he has undone a lot of the things
that donald trump did that are horrible
things we
really i mean listen this is sort of
like
when you turn one you're really in your
second year of life
because of years okay you understand
we're really only three hours into day
two because he wasn't even sworn in till
noon
he didn't even really do stuff until two
or three so like
really everything so far has been the
first day if you if you want to put it
that way
and a lot of right wingers are really
really upset about that uh one example
is ainsley earhart
who is a completely out there
fox news host she's she says
joe biden said unity and then he did
stuff
that's not unity yes she the fact that
biden did things that are different than
trump
is evidence of uh of of not having unity
listen to this
so our country's got to come together
and joe biden said yesterday
i want unity he talked about that in his
speech but the first thing he does the
first order of business
is to walk in sit down at the table and
he has 17 executive orders really wiping
away
much of what president trump did
is biden said unity and then he did
stuff
what what that's not unity no
unity is we are going to go back to
hopefully being respected around the
world
together as americans we're going to go
back to
everybody's part of paris climate but
we're not no we'll go back to be part of
paris climate
uh everybody's part of the who but we're
not no we'll go back to being part of
the who so
this is just you know it's exactly what
uh what we expected from right-wing
media
and it's happening and it's happening
now as far as jen
sackey joe biden's press secretary
yesterday we watched uh together her
first press briefing
and i mean it it was unremarkable in
that she just answered questions
when she didn't have anything to say she
said i don't have anything for you on
that
and she took all the questions people
wanted she didn't have a binder this big
which she turned to for a scripted
walk-off that included denouncing media
as an institution it was just kind of
like okay it's basic
and everybody's enamored of gensake now
she did a good job but
it's it's just a sign of how much we've
been missing
being able to just hear like oh what's
biden been up to
what's his b view on stuff what do we
expect that he's going to do
it's not about we'll agree with
everything but it's just
some sense of getting back to something
normal in some way shape or form so
we're going to hear from her at the top
of the hour 20 minutes from now
and hopefully get some more updates on
what joe biden did today
uh 10 i believe it's 10 more executive
orders
and um i think i think it's going to be
really great okay so we've got that
by the way uh joe biden just moments ago
asked
isn't 100 million doses in 100 days not
ambitious enough now what's funny is
i said this a month ago a month ago i
said
we should be we should be at a million a
day by the time biden takes over anyway
and indeed we are we've been lately ada
where have we been
we're already at 912 000 a day so as
i've been saying
um you know it's not going to be a
million a day would be really a failure
in my view
but you know you're under promising and
hopefully over delivering and
joe biden was actually pretty funny when
he was asked about this moments ago
he said you know first you guys said it
wouldn't be possible now you're saying
it's not enough take a listen
thank you guys is that china far higher
that's basically where the us is right
now
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break man
so listen it is a good start if we're
seeing it as a start then that that is
great um
but uh we're gonna need to do much more
than a million a day of course
one thing i really don't like and this
is not a democrat republican thing
i don't like someone who starts to
scream thank you press
thank you thank you to interrupt the
questions they did listen to it
there must be some other way to kind of
signal that it's over and of course
reporters
have more questions and they'll keep
yelling questions out
i wasn't a fan of this under under trump
i'm not a fan of it under
under biden either they're having
someone just yell and say thank you
press come on like escorting them out
like they're
uh you know cows being moved from one
paddock to another or something like
that
i find it i just find it unnecessary
there's got to be some other way
uh to treat to treat people like adults
uh but that is a relatively uh
relatively minor concern in the grand
scheme of things
let me go to a few uh super chats
benjamin says latest righty conspiracy
the inauguration didn't take place
yesterday and it was pre-recorded
because it was sunny and the forecast
called for snow
yeah that's wacky that's wacky
should we take a moment to appreciate
the fact that she admitted that most of
what trump did could be undone in one
afternoon yeah
in the ainsley clip where she says in
three hours biden undid four years of
what trump did
that's a sign trump didn't really do
that much
trey says it's because we just got out
of a four-year-long abusive relationship
so literally anything remotely like
normalcy is a breath of fresh air well
said
um astro diddle says when will biden
announce his plan to abolish capitalism
and institute marxism
yeah i tweeted about this yesterday
during the oh by the way
it's gotten really annoying bernie just
sits over there with a microphone
wearing a mask ready to take over
anytime i say something wrong
super super annoying yes senator yes i
know i know
yeah anyway um that is i don't know that
that that's gonna
that's gonna get grading after a little
bit
um but i did where did i tweet this
yesterday
uh hold on a second wow i sent out way
more tweets than i thought oh here it is
does the communism start right away and
we're still missing the communism
we're still we it still hasn't started
uh and
really really funny listen to this
this is hold on where is it this is an
exclusive
listen to who sean hannity is going to
be interviewing today
the media they're going to spend any
time ever investigating the biden family
crime
syndicate allegations nefarious dealings
with
all of these countries that don't have
america's best intention at heart
tomorrow on this program as i said we'll
have the delaware laptop repairman
he has hunter's hard drive quite frankly
the media
did all of the biden's bidding in the
election but they didn't really do him
favor
that's right guys he will be
interviewing the hunter biden laptop
repairman
uh he is going to give us his take on
whether windows
3.11 was really that much
better than windows 3.1 and also weigh
in on the explosive issue as to whether
minesweeper on the hardest difficulty
is just too difficult okay so
those explosive stories tonight on
uh hannity you can expect it looks like
even he himself doesn't think that the
interview is that interesting
like it at this point it's just a parody
of itself you know
a big thank you to sharon kiera sharon
kayera
just grabbed a membership at
jointpakman.com i appreciate that thank
you so much
also thanks to trisha eastman for the
twitch prime sub
and farrar very very much appreciate
that
um twitch is twitch is happening twitch
is happening i don't even know
what's happening on twitch but i'm told
that uh twitch is is really is really
the thing these days
um oh oh yes they will also debate
you know a three and a half inch floppy
it's not really floppy
and is that a misnomer in some way shape
or form that's also going to be debated
tomorrow or tonight rather on hannity
exclusive exclusive love the show david
would you ever do a collab with brian
tyler cohen yeah anytime
david unrelated question i live in a
shared house with a very talkative
repetitive
housemate he has asperger's how would
you kindly tell him to give me some
space
i don't know anything about that that
that's not i don't i don't uh
there is a lot of undiagnosed autism
spectrum disorder
um and in fact i've met a lot of people
in the political media space
who when i meet them i realize oh this
is this person's autistics
to some degree and it is undiagnosed
it's there's so much undiagnosed autism
i don't know
what has to be done uh i mean it would
seem that it would be better for us to
be diagnosing it
that's my little uh kind of the more you
know disclaimer
but it is very very common blind deaf
and dumb
delaware computer repairman to testify
on hannity about melania nudes found in
a folder called taxes on hunter's laptop
yeah basically
um oh uh
okay i have two things to ask you guys
about
oh thanks to emilia romero for signing
up at jointpakman.com appreciate that
two things to ask you guys about i have
we can go in two directions right now
i have two voicemails i can play for you
one positive one negative one positive
one negative or
i can give you a preview of the uh most
humiliating hundred moments of trump's
presidency video
that we have not yet launched but we'll
be launching later on the youtube
channel
do you want voicemails first or do you
want 100 worst
most humiliating moments first
okay everybody's saying the video fine
we'll do the video first
okay so we are going to be releasing
this
uh later today producer pat
did a hell of a job on this uh we've
been working on this for some time
let's take a look at this should we
start at 100 or start kind of in the
middle and
let's start here i'll just give you guys
a preview of it okay listen to this i
just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
you know if you go out and you want to
buy groceries you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his
own doral golf club take care of the
floors you know the floors of the forest
it's very important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red from suchin
kendo kerr to virot kohli
the new york times they are a true enemy
of the people
i think we have enough of an interview
here hope okay that's enough
let's go this russian bounty story we
have multiple sources saying
that trump knew all along i had
forgotten about so much of this stuff
for a tiny little short period of time
it was much more for an inspection there
was no problem during the day
and said quote crazy joe biden he
doesn't know me
but he would go down fast and hard
crying
all the way they'll go out and they'll
vote and they're going to have to go and
check their vote by going to the poll
and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
that's got to be higher than 85. i might
have to take issue with producer pat i
don't know that the toilet flushing
routine 85 i mean that's i think that
that's got to be a little bit higher
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one all right
trump ordered robert mueller the special
prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is wear a
mask
at all times and trump puts on goggles
but no mask
and we're building a wall in colorado
we're building a beautiful wall trump
floated the idea
of suave puerto rico for greenland
the ramp that i descended after my west
point commencement speech was very long
and steep
had no handrail and most importantly was
very slippery
man the air it ran the ramparts
it took over the airports it did
everything it had to do
wherever trump goes he tries to make
himself seem dominant over whoever he's
shaking hands with trump's
strong-looking situation room photo was
a staged
photograph likely taken hours after the
event
to lock them up you should lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary i
too have a nuclear button
but it is a bigger and more powerful one
than his
the nars assistant chief donald trump
wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks
he's not reading a presidential daily
briefing
that has been dumbed down to one page
we'll do a couple more pictures graphs
and maps
get that son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now
he's fired he's fired
so in florida i encourage all to request
a ballot and vote by mail
right when direction shifted and it sort
of split his hair
back trump was laughed at by the entire
room of world leaders at the united
nations one of the wettest we've ever
seen
from the standpoint of water water dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps i
think
massive dumps should be higher than 64.
let's just do a couple more
our ball is unaccepting of what i did
for his son
i should have left them in jail these
aren't people
these are animals the same vaccine could
not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
cummings district is a disgusting rap
all right so anyway those are the top 40
but this is gonna go live later today
please do me a favor
uh please share that video okay when
that goes live
please share it i'm not even gonna tell
you what number one is number one is
just absolutely crazy
uh okay big thank you to david floyd who
signed up at joinpackman.com very much
appreciate that
uh david very very powerful also thanks
to the 10 folks who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions love that
absolutely love it uh what did i think
of amanda gorman yesterday i thought she
was fantastic
incredible poise incredibly poised
the airports in the 1800s really made me
laugh yeah that was great
i live in colorado and still don't know
why or where the wall would be built
yeah i don't either i don't either okay
so let me do the voicemails now i uh
so many of you have come to like the
voicemails from this
v disgusting trumpist troy york
the eggman who is a friendly caller
great caller to the show the eggman
is trying to cancel troy york okay what
do you guys think about this
take a listen to the eggman's
perspective he says no more troy york
voicemails hey man listen um i'm not
calling as a listener of your show
i'm calling as a junior junior junior
junior junior executive
producer of your show um come on over
ten years i get to have some uh
some input here's my input stop [ __ ]
playing troy york's voice message
and going through it point by point
that is aggressive of all of his lives
yes you're a thousand percent correct
but this dude has a full erection
beating off to you playing his [ __ ]
and analyzing it point by point that's
all he wants okay
um every point that you countered with
that you've made
multiple times we don't need dude that's
you're almost like i hate to say dave i
love you but it's you're thin skinned in
a way that you can't let him get one
voice message past you i'm very
no so that's what's funny i only play
about a quarter of troy york's
voicemails that's the that's a funny
thing that's an interesting
element to consider he has plenty of
that do but just look leave him
be the dude is getting off on this [ __ ]
[ __ ] troy york that's how you [ __ ] guys
like that don't play his voice message
and he'll be [ __ ] crying into the
ethernet into [ __ ] his
black hole dark web um otherwise holy
[ __ ] joe biden is president this is
[ __ ] great
i love you patrick shalom to all you
guys
uh junior executive producer eggman
finding out
all right so there's the eggman uh
shalom of course to the eggman
uh peace and love so anyway i i see
people who are on
on his side and people who are not on
his side so that's something to think
about
and then lastly um over the last few
weeks
we've had just massive dumps of new
viewers come in because of the various
live streams and viral videos
here's someone who prefers this is kind
of funny someone who says
i should shut up during the live streams
take a listen to this
trying to listen to the press conference
and the constant interruptions by
mr pakman are very distracting
that's why i usually watch c-span
because they just let you
visual see what's happening
without a whole lot of rhetoric from
other folks right that's fine that's
just not
this channel and i've said this before
c-span is still available you don't
nobody's forcing you to watch here the
whole point here is sometimes i'll
interject
sometimes i'll interject that but
there's other options that's the great
thing about the marketplace of ideas
uh you know just keep watching c-span
and i totally would respect that that's
really no big deal i love that
there's options for everybody thanks for
holly brush who just signed up at
joinpakman.com very much appreciate that
holly
and yes the coupon code is legal we have
gotten special dispensation
um that we thought the coupon code would
be made
illegal by joe biden but it is working
better 21 you go to joinpakman.com
it's a beautiful beautiful thing um
okay let's look at super chats here
ren holder says i agree about the troy
york wow
hi david i'm the guy who suggested you
write a david pakman cookbook and offer
it as a gift at the higher membership
levels i'd like to offer my help
in producing the book if you need it how
do i contact you
you know we used to do a um
we used to do a yearly calendar it's
just
so much work and the truth is what we
figured out was
the amount of work to sell
200 calendars or something like that
it just didn't make sense and in the era
particularly of the virus
we've gotten more and more away from um
from physical items so i don't know i
just don't know if it makes sense to do
that and certain i mean listen there's
no shortage of recipes
we would obviously include my recipe for
my jewish brisket
my avocado toast recipe with harissa
of course i mean come on who wouldn't
want that my spanish tortilla recipe
uh you know how to make a dirty chai
without humiliating yourself
um oh it could be done as a pdf i didn't
even think about that right it could be
a digital cookbook that's interesting
that's interesting my milanesa of course
i mean you've got to have milanesa
and we will actually do a we should hold
a debate on if and whether there's a
difference between milanesa and
wienerschnitzel i think that that would
be explosive
but anyway we'll we'll keep thinking
about it okay we'll keep thinking about
it
my once liberal father taught me and my
brother's acceptance and equality of
all people and now supports trump and
uses racial slurs what do i do
that's a pretty big matzo ball uh to
figure out what to do with that i don't
know
that's tough mcconnell already saying
biden has taken many steps in the wrong
direction already divisive not even a
day in yeah i mean we knew that was
going to happen of course
of course the illegal coupon code joke
is getting really
old stop oh no we've stopped it it's not
we there's a we got an executive
order the coupon codes are legal so it's
it's over
your most recent member town hall on
your website predates the trump
administration any thoughts on bringing
those back
maybe maybe
yeah we're thinking about that for sure
i mean it's
there's just so many different that we
weren't doing any streams at the time
remember
so that's uh that's an important pretty
important thing to keep in mind i think
um if we had the time i'd like to look
at a little bit of tucker carlson's
uh diatribe i'm sorry monologue from
last night
let's look at a little bit of it okay
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy inauguration day
it's a big moment for the country
the changing of that buzzing that's a
weird noise
that's weird hard a peaceful transfer of
power
another reassuring sounds like a bad
ground display of the awesome pageantry
of constitutional government
there were solemn speeches today sworn
oaths belted
anthems all echoing against the backdrop
of 26
000 smartly attired federal troops who
were guarding our capital city from
unseen threats it was quite a display
was all a lot to take really
so like many of you we flipped on the
tube to see what it meant
and here's what we learned joe biden
respects government he respects people
who disagree with him he listens to them
i think that joe biden is going to train
us to see the world differently he plans
to usher in a new era of hope
and the action he's promising the minute
he takes office we've gone from
indecency
to decency he filled that empathy void
there was not one part of that that
wasn't just medicine
in the world those lights that are that
are
just shooting out from the lincoln
memorial uh along the reflecting pool
i look it's like almost extensions of
joe biden's arms embracing america it
was a moment
maybe a bit more new president came to
town
so to recap joe biden respects people's
differences but at the same time he's
going to train us to be very different
from the way we are
now i haven't i haven't heard biden say
he's going to train us to be different
from the way we are this is how tucker
gets people
by arguing against straw men
i think biden's message has been we
actually are already really good
but trump has been divisive and has
brought out the worst in some people
i don't i think tucker is making a claim
here he's arguing against something
biden hasn't said it's kind of cringey
bring hope and decency he will fill the
yawning void where our empathy should be
he is medicine joe biden's arms lean and
hard from
decades of empathetic labor on our
behalf will encircle us like lights from
the lincoln memorial and at that point
well god knows anything is possible if
there's a thin
bead of sweat forming on your upper lip
as you think about all of this that's
okay
don't feel shame shame isn't necessary
now joe biden is here
and not just joe biden hey what is
tucker talking about
the hell is he talking about jill biden
too
mrs biden dr biden together the two of
them msnbc informed us
will redeem this nation through their
love
behold what a story though what a great
love story between
jill biden and joe biden it's just a
different
kind of marriage the this is a a love
match
like the obamas were so i think that i
mean it's like that's true the
relationship between trump and melania
was could could not possibly be more
dysfunctional i don't even see
that this is what tucker's focused on
that'll be healing for the country too
the biden's marriage is healing for all
of us
isn't it better to see that than what we
saw with trump and melania where trump
says i got home and and my and melania
said
sir like that's weird that's really
bizarre for the country
the biden's love is america's love jill
and joe are the mother and father of
this nation
from their loins we are born and yet
reborn oh my god may their names emerge
from our lips in praise forever
and so on that was cable news today the
funny thing is and there are many funny
things going on right now
every person with a microphone in every
tv studio in america today knew the
fuller truth when they said things like
the ones you just heard
they knew for example for certain that
joe biden isn't well
everyone in washington knows that but no
one said it out loud
what word has he been doing i haven't
heard him say that before let me just
see
if we're okay we're still waiting i
didn't realize tucker was doing that
i hadn't heard that from him before
they withheld that news from you as they
have for months
so much for speaking truth to power on
the other hand
what did you expect you've watched the
lying for years now you know what it is
you figured out how it works
so it dawned on us today that maybe we
ought to stop playing all these stupid
media clips every night
it's like watching the town drunk throw
up on himself over and over again
obviously i could say the same thing
about playing tucker's clips
see it's repulsive and shocking it's
hard to turn away but can you really be
surprised by it
throwing up on themselves is what town
drunks do if you keep
watching them as they do it maybe after
a while you are part of the problem
maybe so any case we flipped off cnn and
decided to check out joe biden's speech
for ourselves and it was interesting
actually both for what it said
and for what it didn't say okay one
particular part of this speech stuck out
especially
now we didn't support joe biden for
president you probably guessed that
but if we're being totally honest here
and we want to be honest we have to say
it was very hard to disagree with this
specific part of the address
watch on this january day my
whole soul is in this bringing america
together
uniting our people united in our nation
and i ask every american to join me in
this cause
with unity we can do great things
important things bringing
america together biden said uniting our
people
whoa that's controversial i mean they're
sending rapists and criminals and some
i'm sure are good people
he seems more outraged by that than by
the the quote i just uh uh
sort of reminded people that's very
weird uniting our nation
to which we said as we watch it and we
meant it when we did amen
okay unity that is precisely what this
country
needs more than it needs anything okay
we're all in this
together every single american and we
have no choice
but to hang together let's finally
accept that we are one country and act
like we are
and make this a better place for
everyone oh i'm being told that uh
hold on what's going on here she's at
the podium
neither of these streams have started
yet i don't know why
white house press briefing let's see if
we can get to a different one
no nobody's live yet
i'm sure one of these will start soon
we'll keep i mean what can we do
we'll keep an eye i have no easy way of
getting over to a cnn feed right now
let's see if washington post is live do
a tapper and i'll answer a bunch of your
questions as well
so there's lots to come after this with
that i will turn it over to dr fauci
valjee's here oh here we go we're here
to bring you a briefing at the white
house with
president thank you very much and i'm
going to just spend a couple of minutes
wow
just uh summarizing the status of where
we are
fantastic and then maybe addressing some
of the things that i know are
on people's minds so first of all
obviously we are still in a very serious
situation i mean to have over 400 000
deaths is something that you know is
unfortunately historic in the very
in the very bad sense um when you look
at
the number of new infections that we
have it's still at a very very high rate
hospitalizations are up there are
certain areas of the country
as i think you're all familiar with
which are really stressed
from the standpoint of beds from the
standpoint of the stress on the health
care system
however when you look more recently
at the seven day average of cases
remember we were going between
three and four hundred thousand and two
and three hundred thousand right now it
looks like
it might actually be plateauing in the
sense of turning around
now there's good news in that but you
have to be careful
that we may not be seeing perhaps an
artifact an artifact of a slowing down
following the holidays
so when we see that we think it's real
but one of the things and it's
interesting i'm sort of getting a deja
vu standing up here because i said
something like this
almost a little bit less than a year ago
when we were talking about the
the acceleration of cases in the late
winter early
spring of 2020 when we were having
new york city metropolitan area being
the epicenter of what was going on
that there are always lags so please be
be aware of that that when you have
cases
and then a couple of weeks later you see
it represented in hospitalizations
intensive care and then a couple of
weeks later in deaths
so you have almost a paradoxical curves
where you see something plateauing and
maybe coming down
at the same time as hospitalizations and
deaths
might actually be going up so this is
something that i just
put on your radar screen it is not an
unusual thing
to see that sort of thing the other
point i want to make is one that we're
getting
asked a lot regarding questions and that
is
what is it about these mutants that
you're hearing about
the mutants in the uk which we know are
in about 20 plus states
this is important the mutants that we're
seeing in south africa
and in brazil first of all
we need to understand that rna viruses
like
coronaviruses mutate all the time most
of the mutations don't have any
physiological
relevance with regard to the function of
the virus itself
however every once in a while you get
mutations either singly
or clustered in combinations which do
have an impact so what have we learned
thus far and i want to emphasize thus
far because we're paying
very very careful attention to this and
we take it very seriously
at least from the experience that our
colleagues in the uk have had
the one that is in the uk appears to
have
a greater degree of transmissibility
about twice as much
as what we call the wild-type original
virus the one that is in south africa
is a bit different and i'll get to that
in a second this is great so it does
look like it increases the
transmissibility
they say correctly on a one-to-one basis
it doesn't seem to make the virus more
virulent
or have a greater chance of making you
seriously ill
or killing you however we shouldn't be
lulled into complacency about that
because if you have a virus that is more
transmissible
you're going to get more cases when you
get more cases
you're going to get more
hospitalizations right and when you get
more hospitalizations
you're ultimately going to get more
deaths so even though the virus on a
one-to-one basis
isn't more serious logical phenomenon of
a more transmissible virus
is something that you take seriously
leads to more cases
does it change enough to interfere with
the efficacy of a whole group of
monoclonal antibodies
that many of you are aware of the
monoclonal antibodies that are being
used for treatment in some cases
and prevention since monoclonal
antibodies
bind to a very specific part of
the virus when there's a mutation there
it has much
greater a chance of obliterating the
efficacy
of a monoclonal antibody and we're
seeing in the much
more concerning um uh
mutations that are in south africa and
in some respects brazil which is similar
to south africa that is having an effect
on the monoclonal antibodies the real
question that people
are quite clearly interested in is what
is the impact
on the vaccine right and so far
literally we have this new phenomenon
that our pre-journals where
where people get data and they put it
into a pre-print server where it hasn't
yet been
peer-reviewed but you have to pay
attention to it because
it gives you good information quickly
ultimately it gets confirmed
and we're seeing them coming out over
the last few days
and what they're saying is that what we
likely will be seeing
is a diminution more south africa than
uk
uk is that diminution in what would be
the efficacy
of the vaccine that's not antibodies
now that does not mean that the vaccines
will not be effective and let me explain
why
there's a thing called a cushion effect
so if you have a vaccine like the
moderna and the fisa vaccine
that can suppress the virus at a
dilution let's say of
one to a thousand and the mutant
influences it by bringing it down to
maybe one two
to eight hundred or something like that
you're still
well above the line of not being
effective
so there's that cushion that even though
it's diminished
somewhat it still is affected okay
that's what we're seeing
both certainly with the uk which is very
minimal effect
with why we're following very carefully
the one in south africa
which is a little bit more concerning
but nonetheless
not something that we don't think that
we can handle
what is the message because someone
could say now wait a minute if you have
the possibility that the vaccines are
diminishing in their
impact why are we vaccinating people no
it is all the more reason
why we should be vaccinating as many
people as you possibly can as soon as
possible because as long as the virus is
out there
replicating viruses don't mutate
unless they replicate and if you can
suppress that
by a very good vaccine campaign
then you could actually avoid this
deleterious effect that you might get
from the mutations bottom line we're
paying
very close attention to it there are
alternative plans
if we ever have to modify the vaccine
that is not something
that is a very onerous thing we can do
that given the platforms we have
but right now from the reports we have
literally
as of today it appears that the vaccines
will still
be effective against them with the
caveat in mind you want to pay
close attention to it so jim why don't i
just stop there and then maybe just
answer some questions
what if we hit the body with a very
powerful light
helpful would it have been if amazon got
involved with the federal
response to kobe 19 before
fighting took office and do you know
about any plans
or discussions ahead of yesterday no i
don't think i could
answer that question i'd be waving my
hands about that sorry
well you know one of the new things in
this administration administration's if
you don't know
the answer don't guess just say you
don't know the answer
yeah that's great yes that's a great
policy
i'd like to follow up with you uh on
what you just said about this strain in
south africa has that strain made its
way
to the united states and what if any
concerns do you have how much do we
understand about it great question
thus far it does not appear at all that
the south african strain is in the
united states
however it will be honest and say that
the level of comprehensive
sequence surveillance thus far is not at
the level that we would have liked so we
we're going to be looking very very
carefully for it but
given the information we have today it
doesn't appear that the south african
strain is here okay and if i could
just ask you about the effort to
distribute the vaccines because of
course
that's what makes people want to know
when are they going to get a vaccine
is the biden administration starting
from scratch
with the vaccine distribution effort or
are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is a
switch feeds people want to see the
report information we have
today it doesn't appear that the south
african strain is here
okay if i could just ask you about the
effort to distribute the vaccines
because of course
that's what makes people want to know
when are they going to get a vaccine
is the biden administration starting
from scratch
with the vaccine distribution effort or
are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is
activity going on in the distribution
but if you look at the plan that the
president has put forth
about the things that he is going to do
namely get community vaccine centers up
get pharmacies more involved where
appropriate
get the defense production act involved
not only
perhaps with getting more vaccine but
even the things you need
to get a good vaccine program for
example
needles and syringes that might be more
useful than that
so it's taking what's gone on but
amplifying it in a big way
president biden said that what was left
was abysmal essentially
is there anything actionable that you
are taking
from the previous administration
to get the vaccine i mean that's the
question well we're working out of the
same building coming in
with fresh ideas but also some ideas
that were not bad ideas
with the with the with the previous
administration you can't say it was
absolutely not usable at all so we are
continuing but you're going to see a
real ramping up of it one more final
question you had said that most people
will be vaccinated by
the middle of 2021 is that still your
expectations
yes it is i mean i i believe that the
the goal that was set by the president
of getting a hundred million
people vaccinated in the first hundred
days is quite a reasonable goal
and when you get to the point and and
one of the things that that
i think is is something we need to pay
attention to and i
quite frankly been spending a
considerable amount of my own time
is outreaching particularly to minority
communities
to make sure that you get them to be
vaccinated and you explain why it's so
important for themselves
their family and their community if we
get
70 to 85 percent of the country
vaccinated
let's say by the end of the summer
middle of the summer i believe by the
time we get to the fall
we will be approaching a degree of
normality it's not going to be perfectly
normal
but one that i think will take a lot of
pressure off the american public
you're one of the few holdovers from the
previous administration this current one
what has been uh your experience uh with
this new team
and what would have been different in
terms of the trajectory
of this outbreak from the start had a
team like he's not going to speculate at
the beginning
well i can tell you my my impression of
of
of what's going on right now the team i
don't know if i can
extrapolate other things but one of the
things that was very clear as recently
as about 15 minutes ago
when i was with the president is that
one of the things that we're going to do
is to be completely transparent open
and honest if things go wrong not point
fingers but to correct
them wow and to make everything we do be
based on
science and evidence i mean that was
literally
a conversation i had 15 minutes ago with
the president shouldn't he be denouncing
someone
uh looking back on your comments over
the last 10 or 12 months
would like to now with that sort of
license to to to amend or clarify
no i mean i i always said everything on
the base that's why i got in trouble
sometimes
you mentioned pharmacies uh the new cdc
director said today that the goal of
getting vaccinations
into pharmacies by the end of next month
isn't realistic
as having previously suggested be when
will most americans be able to get a
vaccination
in their neighborhood pharmacy well i'm
i'm i didn't hear that comment are you
talking about dr wolinski's comment i i
didn't hear that comment so i don't
really want to
comment on on the comment but what she
may be saying
is that for many people in this country
who don't have access
to a pharmacy they may not be able to
utilize
getting things in the pharmacy i i'm not
sure i want to be careful because i'm
not sure that's what she said
we just had a conversation about how
we're going to get
vaccines to people who are in pharmacy
desert areas
where they don't have easy access to a
pharmacy right and that's something
we're working on and taking very
seriously
just be clear if you are in an area
where you do have access to a cbs or a
walgreens when will you be able to to
get
back to access to this vaccine like you
would a flu vaccine you know in the
spirit of
not guessing i i really i'm not quite
sure when that will be but we can get
back to you on that that's okay
on the broader timeline you mentioned
the fall we just heard the president say
you know the brutal truth is that it is
going to be several more months
just to be clear you're saying by the
fall the majority of americans no
you think we'll be back no i didn't say
that i said if we get
the majority of americans 70 to 85
percent vaccinated by then we could have
a degree of herd immunity that would get
us back to normal
the concern i have and something we're
working on
is getting people who have vaccine
hesitancy who don't want to get
vaccinated
because many people are skeptical about
that so we really need
to do a lot of good outreach for that
i mean i don't know what the best case
the best case scenario
for me is that we'd get 85 of the people
vaccinated by the end of the summer
if we do then by the time we get to the
fall i think we can approach a degree of
normality
sean spicer has a question on that
mutations that you were talking about
a question about how exactly they
increase transmissibility
is it does it take less exposure time
together
what it is is that you can do in vitro
in a in a
test tube setting binding an affinity to
the receptors which you have in your
nose in your lung and your gi tract
the receptor for the virus is called an
ace ii receptor
and the facility or affinity with which
a virus
binds to that means that it very likely
will have a better efficiency
of infection and replicate more in the
nasopharynx
so that's how you make that
determination in the test tube
then you look epidemiologically and you
see a spike going up in the sense
of number of cases and they sort of
match each other
a virus that has the inability to easily
bind to
and replicate with your receptors is one
that likely will spread easier
so it doesn't mean that you'd have more
viral load
oh you could yes in fact it would mean
because if it binds more easily
it could replicate in the nasopharynx
more easily and it is likely that you
would have a higher viral load
make masks less effective in that case
no it makes it the reason why you
absolutely should be wearing a mask
it doesn't necessarily make it less
effective if you properly wear
a mask then you'll be okay the uk strain
do you have any
any data on how widespread that strain
is in in the united states
that people have mentioned exactly the
the real question that's going to be
asked
is it going to become the dominant
strain or will the strains we already
have
prevent it from flourishing and being in
the more dominant strain
but it is here for sure
some state and local authorities are
saying that they would
be able to distribute more vaccines if
they had more
is the biden administration now trying
to increase production by moderna
good question kaiser in the next six
weeks yeah as well as
to utilize what we hope will be another
player in the field the
j and j johnson as well as other of the
companies
but also as the as the president has
said in his plan
to do whatever he can to expand the
availability
of vaccines whatever that is i mean he
said that he's going to just use every
possibility
including the defense production act can
you explain the discrepancy between what
some states are saying
about needing more vaccines in the cdc
saying that a lot of vaccine is still
remaining on people's or on their
shelves
yeah you know i i think that that is
something that we need to really take a
close look at because that is sort of an
inconsistent
discrepancy and one of the things we
want to do is to find out
why that's the case and if it is the
case particularly
the thing that would be most disturbing
if there's vaccine late
laying around and people are not using
it when others would need it
but i don't know the answer to that
question but we need to look into it
you've joked a couple times today
already about the
difference in that you feel and being
kind of the spokesperson for this issue
in this administration versus the
previous one
can you can you talk a little bit about
how free
how much different do you feel less
constrained
what is the you know i mean you you for
so many times you stood up behind the
podium with donald trump standing
behind you that was a different that was
a different
feeling i'm sure than it is today can
you talk a little bit about
about how you feel uh kind of
released from from what you said last
year
yeah but you said i was joking about it
i was very serious
there was no joke about it i wasn't
joking no actually
i mean i mean obviously i don't want to
be going back
you know over history but it was very
clear that there were things that were
said
uh be it regarding things like
hydroxychloroquine and other things like
that
that really was an uncomfortable because
they were not based on scientific fact
i can tell you i i take no pleasure at
all
in being in a situation of contradicting
the president so it was really something
that you didn't feel that you could
actually say something and there
wouldn't be any repercussions about it
the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what you know
what the evidence what the science is
and know that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating field
basically banished for for a few months
there for a while
you feel like you're back he's getting
awkward i think so
wow okay that's mike shearer you don't
want to take [ __ ] from him
thank
dr fauci that that was great uh well
thank you everyone uh as i promised uh
we'll have a full
briefing from here so as you know
just a few moments ago the president
also released a national covet 19
strategy
and signed 10 executive orders and other
directives to move
quickly to contain the crisis
underpinning everything the president
signed today and everything we do every
day will be equity
some highlights of those actions include
an executive order to fill
supply shortfalls for vaccinations
testing and ppe
the president directed agencies to
exercise all appropriate authorities
including the defense production act to
accelerate manufacturing and delivering
of supplies
such as n95 masks gowns gloves
pcr swabs test reagents and necessary
equipment and material for the vaccine
the president also signed a presidential
memorandum
to increase federal reimbursement to
states and tribes for the cost
of national guard personnel emergency
supplies and the personnel
and equipment needed to create
vaccination centers
an executive order that established a
covet 19 pandemic testing board
to bring the full force of the federal
government's expertise to expanding
testing supply
and increasing access to testing an
executive order to bolster access to
covet 19
treatments and clinical care
establishing a comprehensive and
coordinated preclinical drug discovery
and development program to allow
therapeutics to be evaluated
and developed in response to pandemic
threats
sorry i had to clear my throat there's a
lot here he also
issued an executive order directing the
departments of education and health and
human services
to provide guidance on safe reopening
and operating for schools
child care providers and institutions of
higher education
an executive order on the occupational
safety and health administration
to immediately release clear guidance
for employers to help keep workers safe
from covet 19 exposure an executive
order to require
mass squaring and airports or certain
modes of public transportation including
many
trains airplanes maritime vessels and
intercity
buses and an executive order
establishing a coven 19 health equity
task force something we had previously
announced but making it official today
nothing banning guns recommendations to
the president
for allocating resources and funding in
communities with inequities and covet 19
outcomes
by race ethnicity geography disability
and other considerations these steps
of course build on the actions we
announced yesterday i had an additional
update some of you may have seen this
come out through last late last night
but i wanted to share with you that as a
result of one of the executive orders
president biden signed yesterday the
acting homeland security
secretary issued a memorandum to review
and reset immigration enforcement
priorities
for 100 days beginning tomorrow the
department of homeland security will
pause removals
for certain individuals this pause will
allow the administration to review
and reset enforcement policies and
ensure that resources
are dedicated to the most pressing
challenges and that we have a fair and
effective
for enforcement system rooted in
responsibly managing the border and
protecting our national security
and public safety i had one other item i
just wanted to flag for you
about something the first lady is up to
let me see if i can find that or i will
circle back to it
a little bit later with that uh i'm
happy to your question
zeke why don't you kick us off thanks
jen um
there's some reporting earlier today
about the president's commitment to uh
extending reading extending new start do
you talk
about what the president's directive on
that front has been additionally uh
did he uh he confirmed that the
president requested reports from the
new dni uh for an assessment on
potential
foreign interference in the 2020
election and also the solar winds act
i can confirm that the united states
intends to seek a five-year extension of
new start
as the treaty permits the president has
long been clear
that the new start treaty is in the
national security interests of the
united states
and this extension makes even more sense
when the relationship with russia is
adversarial as it is at this time
new start is the only remaining treaty
constraining russian nuclear forces
and is an anchor of strategic stability
between our two countries and to the
other part of your question
even as we work with russia to advance
u.s interests so too we work to hold
russia to account for its reckless and
adversarial actions
and to this end the president is also
issuing issuing a tasking to the
intelligence community for its full
assessment of the solar winds
cyber breach russian interference in the
2020 election
its use of chemical weapons against
opposition leader alexey navalny
and the alleged bounties on u.s soldiers
in afghanistan
so that's hopefully answered all of it
that was a mouthful and just a change
here for what's happening uh
we are listening in on a news conference
that's what's going on here
the new press secretary for the biden
administration she will become
quite familiar in the days ahead to news
viewers as
this administration resumes the idea
even before the president was
inaugurated yesterday
but uh hopefully we'll have more to
share with you tomorrow on
meetings engagements discussions that
will be going on
with leaders on capitol hill and many
members over the course of the next
several days
as i conveyed to all of you yesterday
his preference and priority is a
bipartisan package and working with
members of both parties
to come to agreement on that because he
believes
that the crises facing the american
people
as we saw the jobs numbers this morning
the unemployment employment insurance
claims i should say we put out a
statement by
our nec director in case you didn't see
that as we've seen and the reports from
dr
fauci just a few minutes ago this is
this crisis is dire
and it requires immediate action and we
hope and expect
members of both parties to work together
to do that we're also not going to take
options off the table
uh so we'll we'll proceed with those
discussions over the next couple of days
go ahead chris if i can just follow up
on that there was some reporting that
there was going to be a meeting
this weekend with a bipartisan group of
lawmakers can you give us any indication
is that going to happen with president
biden or with his economic team is that
your
expectation well i think the reporting
was around a meeting
with nec director brian diese i spoke
with him earlier today he is
definitely going to be engaging with a
range of members and a range of
different groups of members from capitol
hill in the coming days uh
i think we were still working to confirm
specific meetings before i came out here
and i hope to have more
for all of you on that by tomorrow okay
and more broadly speaking
jen president biden has proposed this
1.9 trillion dollar package
you already have some republicans who
say we just passed a stimulus plan
they're not going to get on board with
this mitt romney among them who says you
just
yeah there's a good question as to what
is the path to get that done and they
haven't made it clear at this point
so how does president biden expect to
get this passed with bipartisan support
how does that fit into his broader
message of bipartisanship proposing
something
that's specific well i think it fits
perfectly into his
message of bipartisanship he wants to
work with democrats and republicans to
address the crises that the american
people
are facing whether they live in red
states or blue states or democratic
democrats or republicans the package was
designed
based on recommendations from health
experts from
economists it's been applauded by
everyone from
senator bernie sanders to the chamber of
commerce and there are specific pieces
in there that are meant to serve as a
bridge for the american people including
a large percentage of it that's for
unemployment insurance uh
funding for vaccine distribution
something that is pivotal as we've
already been discussing here today
for reopening of schools so part of the
discussion we'll be having
with members is what what do you want to
cut uh and
uh this is a plan that he feels
addresses the crisis at the moment one
quick follow-up on that the work of the
senate is being held up by this dispute
over
the filibuster where does president
biden come down on that
does he think that there should not be a
filibuster so that the senate could be
following
his work well the president elect spoke
just yesterday as you all saw
about the spirit of working together and
bipartisanship to confront the four
crises facing us
you've already seen him work with
republicans and democrats and
and work toward a bipartisan uh approach
to passing
packages that will address the crises
we're facing yeah but the the filibuster
questions
in his preference uh so that's what
he'll consider priority and preference
but what about the filibuster
go ahead mike share okay see you can
call
[Music]
so i want to push you a little bit more
on on that question
there's this call for unity that the
president made in his speech yesterday
but there has so far been almost no fig
leaf even
to the republican party you don't have a
republican cabinet member like president
obama
obama and i think president clinton had
you
you know the executive orders that he's
come out the gate have been
largely designed at erasing as much of
the
trump legacy as as you can
much of which the republican party likes
and agrees with you've
put forth an immigration bill that has a
path to citizenship but doesn't
do much of a nod towards the border
security and you've got a 1.9 trillion
dollar
uh covered relief bill that has as folks
have said already drawn all sorts of
criticism where
is the where is the actual action
behind this idea of bipartisanship and
when when are we going to see
one of those you know sort of
substantial outreaches that says
this is something that you know the
republicans want to do too
well i guess what i would send back to
there's a lot in there so let me do my
best here but
mike is is unemployment insurance only
an issue that democrats in the country
want do only democrats want their kids
to go back to schools
do only democrats want vaccines to be
distributed across the country
that's we feel that that package he
feels that package is designed
for bipartisan support i will also say
that we've also had some
positive developments um on our
confirmations and our nominees last
night as you all saw
his not the president's nominee now
confirmed
leader first female leader of the
intelligence community was confirmed
with a vote of 85 to 10 84 to 10. you
can check me on that
but an overwhelming vote we we've seen
progress today on on the nomination and
hopeful confirmation of
lloyd austin so there is movement
supported by both
sides of the aisle members of both
parties i think if you talk to democrat
or republicans on the hill which i know
many of you do
they will say um they're not looking for
something symbolic
they're looking for engagement they're
looking to have a conversation they're
looking to have a dialogue
and that's exactly what he's going to do
has the president reached out to
congressional leaders to sit down and
discuss this relief package will he be
how much personal involvement is he
going to have in this process
i expect he will be rolling up his
sleeves and will be quite involved in
this process mary
and he was yesterday was quite a busy
day for him as you all know
his schedule was minute by minute and
his family was here
uh but he was involved even before
yesterday having conversations with
members of both parties
uh picking up the phone and having those
conversations uh he saw of course
members of both parties he invited
leaders from both parties to join him at
church
obviously that wasn't really a
discussion about uh specifics of the
bill
but they did he did have an opportunity
to talk about his agenda and working to
for
working together on his agenda moving
forward but i think he will see him
quite involved in the days ahead
but you will also see the vice president
uh quite involved you will also see
policy leaders like brian dees and
others in the administration quite
involved
and having conversations with both
democrats and republicans
right now to sit down with them well i i
think we will have more to share with
you soon
uh in terms of engagement of many of our
senior officials with members of both
parties and on the defense production
act just to be clear has the
administration actually invoked the
defense production act and
if so can you spell out what changes we
may see because of this
which companies are being asked to make
one good question
well let me give you a very specific
example that helped really make it clear
for me
um one area is to acquire
more low low dead volume syringes and
what that does is these specialized
syringes allow pharmacists and
vaccinators to extract an extra dose
of the pfizer vial so making more doses
available of course
it also prioritizes the defense
production act raw materials that are
used to produce
the vaccine so reducing bottlenecks
and it enables manufacturers us to
empower this is not really an answer the
question is has it actually been invoked
to make sure we have the materials we
need to get the vaccines out the door
and in the arms of
americans in terms of obviously signed
it this afternoon
um i'll have to just circle back with
you on what it mean if it's officially
invoked in this moment or if it takes
some time so basically it's a non-answer
with an anecdote in the middle go ahead
is the white house drafting a
legislative bill
you mean in terms of the the what he
announced last week
last thursday well he announced what his
specific ideas will be and what his
vision is
but right now we're having discussions
with members of both parties as we have
for the last week about
uh what that will look like okay so no
no bill draft coming out of the white
house
well um i'll i'm happy to talk to our
legislative team about that i think what
was important
um to the president was to outline what
his doesn't chanel ryan have a question
actually work right the president
outlines here's the my vision
here's what i think should be in a
package let's have discussions
uh let's have engagements with both
parties and let's see what comes out of
the sausage making at the
other side whoa go ahead i'll come back
to you i'm sorry i can't see
but um just following up on what kristen
asked i don't think i've heard an answer
about
whether the president supports uh
keeping the filibuster or where he sits
on that
is he has he talked to senator perfect
follow-up
what are his thoughts on that i think
what i was conveying to kristin is that
uh the president has been clear he wants
to work with members of both parties and
find bipartisan paths forward
and um i don't have any more
conversations to read out for you at
this point
specifically answer that unless i'm not
understanding your answer i don't think
i have more more to add too
he's not going to answer it and just on
the impeachment trial
um i know that there was some talk about
sort of the senate doing both
both things at the same time two things
at once there's some reporting this
afternoon
that republicans are pushing to have the
impeachment trials start in february
where do you all stand still now on that
are you still looking for that
both paths to happen at the same time
would it be preferable to do that first
or
are you okay with with later as some
republicans are talking about
well i need i think we we have been
pretty consistent that we believe the
timing and the mechanisms for the
congress and the senate moving forward
and holding the former president
accountable
we'll leave that to them and what our
biggest priority and focus is
is ensuring that it doesn't delay uh the
senate
congress moving forward in consideration
and discussion
around the coveted relief package that
the president proposed last week
uh go ahead thank you jen it's a print
cooler i have a question for myself and
then a question for someone who cannot
be here because of the social distance
insurance
my question is this and it's about unity
again i've heard
from conservatives who are afraid that
the president is going to try to pull
back
religious conscience exemptions for
groups like little sisters of the poor
president pledged he would do that in
july when the little sisters won a case
in the supreme court
uh the health and human services nominee
javier visera
pursued that line of going going after
the exemptions as attorney
general of california what's the
president going to do on that
i haven't discussed that particular
issue with him i'm happy to circle back
with you but
i i don't there's not a change in his
position from what he said earlier this
summer
did you have another question question
from adam longa of wusa9
he says we saw the president warmly
greet mayor
bowser during the parade yesterday she
is pushing for the d.c statehood measure
to be on the president's desk within 100
days will the administration get behind
this bill
and does the president support it yes i
hate to disappoint you
but i will have to circle back with you
on that as well you are not going to get
her to take a position on that right now
with him in the last 36 hours i look
forward to hearing okay
sounds great go ahead and back yeah
thanks jeff
um i wanted to circle back on something
related
uh i know the president has obviously
made a priority of
uh getting resuming in-person learning
in the first hundred days i wondered
is the administration planning to issue
any kind of
uniform guidance to states on you know
whether it's reopening schools reopening
businesses
indoor dining stuff like that or are you
all planning to just kind of leave it to
states to do sort of a patchwork based
on their own
this is my son by the way as dr fauci
conveyed our objective is to ensure that
health and medical experts are leading
the effort and delivering guidance
determining guidance and also
communicating it with the public
whenever possible
and any guidance would come of course as
you know from the cdc
uh we and we will we will of course
defer to that
uh but part of our priority and our
focus here is on
providing more engagement with states
more clear guidance from the federal
level
in terms of how we're planning to
operate what data we're seeing
how the how vaccines are being
distributed what we see is the
challenges
and that communication has been lacking
as we understand it from our
conversations in the past few months so
that is what we will
focus on improving in the months ahead
would you specifically or you plan to do
you know
daily or weekly calls with states or how
are you planning to
up the communication well we have an
entire cove team as you know who are now
most of them are official and part of
their
role will be engaging with governors
democrats and republicans
mayors local elected officials to have
gained a better understanding of what's
happening on the ground
that will be how they're going to be in
taking a great deal of information
obviously health
care providers and experts on the ground
as well
we will also do engagement uh from the
level of the president and the vice
president as well because they also want
to have that
conversation with states and local
officials on
what they're experiencing what they see
the challenges as
and and how they can be addressed and
you know that's something
i think in president biden's heart he is
a local
elected official still and and he gets
into the weeds of what they're
experiencing and i and he will be
involved in that himself
there's a lot of really big things that
the administration wants to do
infrastructure
the stimulus tax reform can you sort of
lay out the cadence for us over the
upcoming year
how do you envision unclear those three
major things playing out what's the
order when do you think those will
be taken up but when will they happen
well uh what i can lay out for you on
our first full day here is what our
initial priorities are
um and they revolve around addressing
the four crises that the president
has stated that the country is facing
including
getting the pandemic under control
getting people back to work
addressing our climate crisis and
addressing uh
racial equity
do you think tax reform happens in 2021
i don't really have any predictions for
you on that
um i i think at this point in time and
for the foreseeable future
addressing the pandemic getting the
pandemic under control
and that linkage to uh getting people
back to work will be
his top priority stone xl the decision
yesterday from the president
what would you say to those who have
lost their job or will lost their job
as a result of that decision what would
the message from the president in the
white house be
the message of the president and the
white house would be that he is
committed his record will shows the
american people that he's committed to
clean energy jobs to jobs that
are not only good high-paying jobs
union jobs but ones that are also
good for our environment he thinks it's
possible to do both
he led an effort when he was the vice
president
to put millions of people to work with
those
both of those priorities in mind and he
will continue to
do that as president but he had opposed
the keystone pipeline
back in 2013 when it was when there was
a consideration
of the permit or sorry i don't think it
was 2013 i think it was a little bit
after that
uh and he has been consistent in his
view and he was delivering on a promise
he made to the american public during
the campaign
um go ahead all the way in the back
thank you i wanted to ask you about
india relationship what is president
biden's
vision of india oh the hack the
relationship between the world's oldest
and world's largest democracies
well first i would say that president
biden
who of course has visited india many
times
respects and values the long bipartisan
successful relationship between leaders
in
india and the united states he looks
forward to a continuation of that
obviously he selected and and yesterday
she was sworn in um the first indian
american
to serve as president or vice president
is certainly a historic moment
for all of us in this country but a
further um
you know cementing of the importance of
our uh relationship
so go ahead george yeah thanks uh
two questions about good one on the on
the hatch act
will this administration take that
seriously and do you think it's ever
appropriate
for this white house to have a political
event or political meeting
well as you know there are some
political events that are
acceptable but we certainly take the
hatch act seriously
and we'll abide by that and you will not
see a political uh rally on the
south lawn of the white house with pres
under president biden the second one
this may sound trivial but
presidents and candidates have some
events where
they're fun for the candidate the big
crowd
and the acceptance speech of the
convention the big crowd
at the inauguration big rallies
because of covet this president has
been denied all those has he ever been
at all wistful about sort of missing the
fun parts of uh
his priority is getting to work for the
american people the inauguration
not not not in front of me george i i
will say that even yesterday
um or of the last couple of days you
know he tried to find a moment of joy
uh with his family and with his
grandchildren who bring him great a
great deal of joy and
uh a recognition of uh
of course the great responsibility he
has on his shoulders but
a a moment in history uh that uh
that he was uh playing a very important
part of wasted he's been in public
office as you all know for decades
and he's had many joyful moments but he
also prefers cookie dough over pistachio
ice cream
a crisis where thousands of people are
dying from a pandemic every day
millions of people are out of work is
not
really a time for daily joy as the
leader of the free world and he's
focused on on doing
his job to get the work done for the
american people go ahead
why weren't president and all members of
the biden family masked
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed an executive order that
mandates masks on federal lands at all
that's peter douchey from spock
the inaugural memorial yes
i i think steve he was celebrating uh
an evening of a historic day in our
country and certainly he signed the mask
mandate because
it's a way to send a message to the
american public the answer is that
the mask mandate doesn't apply in
specific situations for on-camera events
covid precautions as you know here in
terms of testing
social distancing mass squaring
ourselves as
as we do terrible answer there is a
stupid question and there's a good
answer terrible and terrible answer but
as uh joe biden often talks about uh it
is not just important the
uh example of power but the power of our
example was that a good example for
people who are watching might not pay
attention
normally well steve i think uh the power
of his example is also
uh the message he sends by signing 25
executive orders including
almost half of them related to kovid he
wasn't ready for this requirements that
we're all under every single day here to
ensure we're sending that message to the
public
yesterday was a historic moment in our
history he was inaugurated as president
of the united states he was we'll talk
about this
family we take a number of precautions
but
i don't think i think we have big bigger
issues to to worry about at this moment
in time
go ahead anita you mentioned oh sorry
jeff
let me go to jeff and yeah because i
already went to you if that's okay
thanks very much
follow up on the new start do you have
any
indication from russia that they will
object to
the extension of five years and has the
united states already alerted moscow
about its desire
uh well we have not obviously as you
know a number of our nominees have
talked about our intention
during their confirmation hearings over
the past couple of days of
extending new start uh i don't have any
calls to read out for you but i
can check and see if any uh
notifications or discussions have
happened this afternoon
and a follow up on something from
yesterday um which i think you referred
to that president biden had said that
was a really bad answer on the masks and
we're going to talk about it
and he didn't want to talk about it
until he spoke to president trump
our president biden and president former
president trump
going to have a call there's no call
plans
what he was conveying is that he didn't
want to release a private note
without having agreement from the former
president
but i wouldn't say he's seeking it
through a phone call he just was
even trying to be respectful uh in that
moment of a private letter that was sent
with regard to the former president has
president biden spoken to speaker pelosi
at all about the timing
of when she plans to bring the
impeachment article for people saying
this is her first time doing this
it's not she was spokesperson for i
believe it was the state department
and she also ran white house comms for
obama so that's not true conversations
are and what his intention is with his
engagements with
leaders from both sides of the aisle and
in both houses of congress including
with speaker pelosi someone he's known
for quite some time
and that is his intention and focus on
getting the uh covid package through
uh so he will leave it to her and to
now uh leader schumer to determine what
the path forward and the timeline will
be
in holding the former president
accountable uh anita go back to you
yeah you uh earlier mentioned four
priorities
of the president i was surprised to not
hear
immigration for saying that because
yesterday many of the executive orders
were about immigration
there were two major agency releases
last night about immigration
the bill is being introduced today do
you not see that as sort of the second
big push after the covet bill where do
you see that
and i guess i would say why is it i was
going to ask you why
is it going to be you know why is it
such a priority after the coping bill
but you didn't even list it so i wanted
to kind of clarify that and get your
thoughts on it
well i i wouldn't i wouldn't uh read
into that other than immigration we
consider as part of racial equity
um and part of uh which is a broad issue
but that's how
the president has spoken about uh that
crisis over the past several months and
clearly it is an enormous priority to
him because
uh he we moved forward in announcing the
specifics
of an immigration bill an immigration
package he is
eager to move forward on with congress
on his first day in office
but as you know there's been a lot of
history on efforts to
do comprehensive immigration reform to
do any form of immigration reform
and what we're hopeful is that this will
be a moment of reset
and a moment to restart discussions on
capitol hill
there are already a number of
co-sponsors who have been announced
to have those discussions there are
experts on immigration who have
worked on this issue on both sides of
the aisle historically it is an issue
there that there is bipartisan support
support from the business community
supports from a range of outside groups
with uh with different
uh political tilts and we're hopeful
that that will help propel it forward
senator menendez said today on a call he
called it a herculean
you know effort to get this through as
you know it hasn't gone through as you
just
mentioned before i mean there are
republicans
grumbling today that there's not more in
that bill that they want to see so
is that bill what do you think the
prospect of that bill getting through
is well i don't know that i can predict
that the first
day i mean it's only been out for 24
hours but
what was important to the president in
the outline of this bill
is that it is addressing a couple of
areas that he doesn't feel have been
effectively done in the past
the last four years the immigration
policy has been
based around funding for a wall that has
not worked even to keep the country
safer
even to keep bad actors out and so
his approach is multi-pronged it is to
do smart security
security that will help address and use
technology to address
key border crossings address ports of
entry
more effectively and efficiently and
putting that oversight in the hands of
the department of homeland security
it will also help address root causes
of migration and that hasn't been in
past bills as you probably well know
anita it was not in the bill in 2013 but
it's something that he has been an
advocate for in his time in public
office
and it also has a pathway to citizenship
for the amount 11 million
uh undocumented immigrants who are
living in the country there are
components of here
in the bill that address a lot of the
issues um that have have not
uh been addressed in the past and and
certainly um
the components of it uh that that make
that are talk about smart security are
the kind of border security that we
think
um is essential and more effective than
what we've seen over the past couple of
years
oh can i go to zeke first and then two
person go ahead
i just want to follow up with a question
again
about the 100 million vaccines in the
first hundred days
that's roughly a per diem basis of where
where the vaccinations are right now
you just elaborate a little bit why the
president isn't setting the bar a little
bit higher he may be
a little required another nudge and just
to explain these people they see these
statistics in view
one tracker had 1.6 million yesterday so
why isn't the president shooting
a little bit higher given the magnitude
of the crisis here well none of us are
mathematicians myself included so i
asked our
team to do a little math on this so the
trump administration was given 36
million doses
when they were in office for 38 days
they administered a total of about 17
million shots that's about
less than 500 000 shots a day what we
are proposing is to double that
to about 1 million right the issue is
we're already there
and we we have uh outlined this goal and
objective
in coordination and consultation with
our health and medical experts so
it is uh ambitious it's something that
we feel is bold
and was called that certainly at the
time uh and we're
working overtime to help to achieve it
try to achieve it but
it is president trump obviously we try
to exceed that if possible is it isn't
possible we may see it in you know in
a couple of weeks or months that the
president of that goal
well there are a lot of factors that go
into
determining how many shots can get into
the arms of americans we feel
confident we can achieve this goal uh
obviously there are
other vaccines that are being considered
at this point in time by the fda
there is funding that will be needed
this is one where she can say it would
bring joe biden no greater pleasure than
to be able to go way beyond
the minimum he wants to achieve this is
on
what many health health and medical
experts have consistently called a bold
goal
i will note also that some of the
reporting this morning which kristen
asked about earlier was that
the trump administration left us with no
plan it's hard for them to both be
exactly true at the same time and our
team has been
putting together a plan our own plan as
dr fauci talked about
for some time to achieve this goal but
he also mentioned that there are a
number of challenges
it's not just about lining people up as
you all know but for people
watching um in a football stadium and
giving them shots we have to overcome
vaccine hesitancy we have to get to
health see if i were her it's okay guys
it's okay you're not gonna miss anything
important
what i would say is listen it's great
that over the last week we've gotten to
900 000
a day uh in order to sustain that
particularly when some states are
starting to run out of that first
vaccine delivery to be able to
get to and sustain a million a day is
still important
and it would give no greater pleasure to
the president to be able to go well
beyond that
former president trump's staffers be
placed on leave or
be reassigned is there an attempt to
purge trump officials well there's a
new administration so obviously there
are a number of new officials in place
uh i know there was some reporting for
example and i don't know if this is who
you're referencing so you tell me if not
of the head of the nlrb that's an
individual who was not
um carrying out the um uh
you know anyone would tell you not just
from our administration uh the
objectives of
uh the nlrb and so they were they're no
longer in their position and
we'll we'll take make those decisions as
needed there's not an effort written
large
but you're assessing reassessing and
developing
as you know when a new administration
comes in there's a massive change over
in political appointees and nominees and
and people who will serve in a variety
of roles there are some people
um christopher wray as an example i'll
just bring him back up who will continue
to serve in his role
uh but will he though we have great
value for career officials for
the officials who have been the heart
and soul of agencies across government
since long before the trump
administration
but who have served through the trump
administration as well
did the transition officials know before
yesterday that amazon wanted to get
involved in such a meaningful way
not that i'm aware of i'm happy to check
i mean when the reporting came out
i asked the question and i think
internally
and you know what was conveyed to me and
i don't think we discussed this
yesterday was that
we've had a lot of outreach um some
privately some publicly from a range of
businesses and private sector entities
and we certainly welcome that
and we'll be considering all of those
offers and what makes the most sense in
our
uh plans and proposals so because there
are some trump officials saying they
were never offered help from amazon and
so they're
essentially saying they think this was a
political call
i'm not aware of the timeline of when
amazon reached out that sounds like a
question for amazon to me
what did you think about all the pardons
that trump handed out on his way out the
door
and do you know if the doj or anyone is
reviewing any of those
uh well as you know we nominated an
attorney general just a couple of weeks
ago merrick garland
were eager to get him confirmed in the
coming weeks hopefully soon
we our view on the pardons
uh jennifer is that it's not the way
it's not a model
for how a biden justice department would
work it's not a model i should say for
how
president biden would use his own power
he would use his own power far more
judiciously
but we are looking forward and
most important for us and for him is
that
the justice department uh as we look
ahead is independent
uh makes decisions of their own accord
including their review of
any investigations or uh judicial steps
that have been taken
thank you i think we're about to
conclude it here but because it's my
second day let's take two more questions
yeah is the president going to listen to
the party attorney
president bush told president obama
that he should use the pardon power
early on but we know that
uh the the pardon power has been in
disrepute in the last week
because of president trump's pardons
what is president going to try to lose
the power quickly or i mean you said
judiciously
what did you just say it's day two i
don't know who he's going to pardon
and i'm not saying you're conveying this
but just for clarity is not meant to
in convey speed it's just meant to
convey how he approaches it as you know
he has a long history on
uh judicial issues having served as the
chairman of the judiciary committee many
years ago
uh but on day two i don't have any
prediction for you
in terms of how he would use a part
pardon attorneys or the role but he has
great respect for and value for uh
independence as you know um and for the
role of the judiciary
um and the independence of that role
okay last last
that may or may not have happened can
you tell us president biden spoken to
the fed chair
jay powell if he hasn't does he have any
plans on speaking to him at any point in
the near future and
generally speaking how does the
president view
the stewardship of the fed chair during
this economic crisis
i don't have any calls to read out for
you or to predict for you
with the chairman of the federal reserve
he clearly has a great deal of respect
and value for the federal reserve and
the role they've played historically
given he nominated the former chair to
serve as the first female treasury
secretary
um but i don't have anything more for
you and can venture to get more for you
from our economic team thank you
everyone i'll see you again tomorrow
so let's go back to the peter ducey mask
question if we can let me see where that
was
uh was it this one no it was
after this guy wow it's real this
timeline is like so long that this is
really difficult
okay i'm having trouble fight i didn't
realize this was like a 10 hour long
video but
the the way i would have answered oh
here it is hold on uh example of
power but the power of our example was
that a good example for people who are
watching who might not pay attention
uh normally so the way i would have
answered this would have been to say
listen uh we just successfully removed
an administration that failed miserably
and historically on coronavirus
where donald trump refused to wear a
mask and mike pence refused to wear
masks even sometimes when visiting covid
patients at hospitals if you can imagine
that
as you know peter or steve or whoever
you are
um that uh in dc if you
are in an on camera setting and not
around anyone else you don't have to
wear a mask that being said
joe biden wore his mask other than when
speaking yesterday throughout the thing
he was with his wife at the lincoln
memorial uh not around anybody else
everybody
having been tested who was even remotely
participating here uh
and uh to even suggest that that has any
bearing compared to what we just removed
over the last year
is absolutely pathetic right i mean so
like that's the gist of it and if i were
her i would obviously be more
prepared but i would have gone with
something like that
now um marjorie taylor greene has
filed for the impeachment of joe biden
on president joe biden
we'll see how this goes just filed
articles of impeachment on president joe
biden
we'll see how this goes okay so there is
marjorie taylor green
announcing that articles of impeachment
have been put forward
against joe biden all right everybody so
that's going to do it for me today
please make sure that you subscribe to
my youtube channel and follow me on
twitch we will have much more coming up
uh it is only day two my friends i
appreciate you joining me
you